All right
introduce characters, our actors
here is John Bradley
Next up, we have Rose Leslie
Christopher Kit Harington
Got Sophie Turner in the house!
Natalie Dormer
We've got a fellow named, Gorge RR Martin.
Thank you
Maisie Williams
Rory McCann
Gwendoline Christie
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau
Pedro Pascal
And finally, our excellent moderator, Craig Ferguson
Thanks very much indeed for saying that, person who's not telling  the truth! I'm very happy to be here, everyone
Thank you, David and Dan, for introducing me last after these people camp out all night to see these people,
and then, at the very end, me!
I thought you understood dramatic structure.
It's very nice to be here!
Welcome to San Dee-ah-go
Which, as we know, is as far south as south goes.
Do you remember that it`s from season two isn`t it? I thought you guys knew about that.
Welcome to the big one. Now of course we`re all here to celebrate Game of Thrones.
I, I understand that many of you people today will know this show better than I do,may of course this people do.
And certainly you will. I know there are people who are fluent in Dothraki out there right now.
But remember we`re all in the same side.
How often do you get.. do you get to see each other?
any point there are all these different worlds that you exist
Do you guys ever get to hang out together?
In the bar.
In the bar?
Yeah.
is there a bar like somewhere that isn't in the title sequence that pops out and you know the right place to go
yeah. its like the starwars bar but it's the game of thrones bar
I can imagine probably is.
It's called the white walker
Now the things is you are.. I am surprised to see you here Rory given your what happened, you were left on the mountain side
So I'm still sore I can't believe that I'm here just.
Yeah things weren't looking to good the last time I saw myself so.
I thought he got off lightly
Nasty bitch
Which one like me or her?
I can't believe I've been put between these two.
I feel very very uncomfortable.
George may I ask you a question?
Yeah.
When you began the  creation of..all
of-- this world of Westeros
and all of the attendant
stories that happen therein
did you envisage anyone to..look like these people?
Does it look like the world you first thought of?
Does it feel like it?
Well, more or less, but,..of course, not exactly.
I mean, I started this in 1991
and the show--I didn't even have my first..meeting with David and Dan until, I believe it was, so there were, like, 16 years before the show was a..twinkle in anyone's eye
and the show--I didn't even have my first meeting with David and Dan until 2007, I believe it was, so there were, like, 16 years before the show was a twinkle in
I believe it was, so there were, like, 16 years before the show was a twinkle in anyone's eye
and I had very strong pictures of what Westeros look like
and what the characters looked like
but these people have brought the characters to life-- you know amazingly.
Does it affect your writing since when you watch the show and continue to write?
Does it inform what you do now?
No,not really 'cause I do have those 16 years that sort of took deep root before the show came along.
Sometimes it gets a little tricky,
but the show is the show and the books are the books and I try to keep them separate.
I know a few of the actors have read the books, but many of them don't.
Can I ask which actors here were reading the books before they became cast members on the show?
Is that something you all do?
or not, as the case maybe?
It certainly isn't prerequisite
obviously
You guys clearly were fans of the books, right?
When did you first come in contact with   them?
The first book
about eight years ago.